Okay we're down to the final idea in
our acronym, which is the letter S for
Style consistently.
Now, the thing to
understand about this idea
is that it does not matter which
style guide a student decides to use
as long as they are consistent with the
styles they use throughout their code.
This means that if the student is using
the Google Python style guide and
are defining a class in this manner
where the first letter of each word is
capitalized, they should follow that
same guide throughout their code and not
do something like this, where the first
letter of each word is not capitalized.
What matters here is consistency
throughout the code.
Let's look at another example of this.